hey David I know people are talking
about Marshall Law and Trump canceling
the election what's really the craziest
thing that Trump could do before the
2020 election so listen here's the
important thing to understand I agree
with many in our audience that Donald
Trump has the potential to be erratic
dangerous and destructive because of how
unhinged he is becoming due to the
impeachment trial that is upcoming due
to the you know embarrassment that he I
think recognizes he has become the
laughingstock he has become in front of
many of our world allies I agree that he
has the potential to act in really
erratic unhinged dangerous ways some of
the things that he could do and then
we'll get into how likely these things
are there's the idea he could cancel the
twenty20 election he could cancel it on
the basis that you know Ukraine has
hacked it and it's not gonna be fair or
something like that he could cancel it
on the basis that while a president is
under impeachment there couldn't
possibly be a fair or like he could try
to do that would he succeed I don't
think so
the other ideas could Trump Trump
declare martial law either before the
election or after the election the
question here is before the election
sure he could try to do it you do need
congressional approval for martial law
we talked last week or the week before
if you go back and look at other
instances where martial law has been
declared in the United States it's been
really when there have been emergencies
now often martial law was used to do
really horrible things like after the
bombing of Pearl Harbor as an example so
that's another possibility
Trump would need Congress to do that and
I don't think that a Democratic Congress
which we will have up until the 2020
election is going to be willing to do
that
another thing Trump could do is try to
get States to cancel elections so we've
already seen that there have been some
states where the Republican Party has
been canceling the Republican primary to
prevent any kind of a challenge to
Donald Trump in the Republican primary
within those those states the the idea
that would be the next step would be go
to red states that have you know really
solidly read a Republican governor and a
republican-controlled legislature how
Senate and try to cancel the election at
the state level all together
this seems number one extremely unlikely
and number two actually
counterproductive because if only red
states cancel the election that's not
good for Donald Trump so I don't see
that as a likely scenario either another
possibility that's been floated around
is something that wouldn't be unique to
Donald Trump it would be getting some
kind of military engagement bomb someone
start a war curry favor as a wartime
president to try to justify this totally
ridiculous notion of we don't want to
change horses midstream you know if your
horse is failing you and you would die
if you stay on the horse but maybe you
can swim to safety
you might try to change horses midstream
to use that analogy that is always a
possibility how many countries have been
possibilities for this many it's her
Trump talked about Venezuela
Trump has talked about Iran Trump has
talked about North Korea there's a long
list that's always sort of a possibility
I actually think that the more dangerous
scenario would be one that's less
cartoonish in nature I don't think
martial law is likely I don't think
canceling elections is likely imagine
that Donald Trump is acquitted in the
Senate impeachment trial which is the
most likely scenario that could set him
off not by anger but into this kind of
manic imaginary mandate that he might
believe he has even if more than half
the country wants have impeached and
removed because Republicans control the
Senate they can acquit him very very
simply I fear that he will become even
more of a megalomaniac by being
acquitted and start doing all sorts of
crazy things with regard to our allies
maybe executive orders and policy and
that would get less attention than
something as as notable as I'm declaring
Martial Law I'm trying to cancel
election and it could actually succeed
in doing quite a bit of damage we will
see I hope none of these things happen